these behemoths are some of the world's
largest marine creatures the giant
oceanic manta ray spans up to seven
meters and weighs up to two tons since
2012
Peruvian biologist Kirsten forsberg has
been fighting to protect the sea
creatures this species is in danger
across the globe due to intentional
fishing and accidental bycatch we have
to do something because here in Peru
there were no regulations to protect the
giant manta ray so we had to take action
on behalf of this species which is at
risk of extinction forest burger is
trying to conserve one of the most
important giant manta ray populations in
the world the docile creatures are not
dangerous to people although there's no
denying they're imposing the waters off
the coast between Peru and Ecuador are
rich in plankton
it's an optimal habitat for the mantas
every dive there is rewarded with
scientific discoveries each giant manta
ray has a unique pattern on its abdomen
it's like a fingerprint that's why when
we dive with them we photograph will
film their abdomen in order to identify
the individual creature
she's one of the first scientists to
research the giant manta ray population
in Peru and the results are alarming
she's very slow to reproduce they
produce only a single puff every two to
seven years and they don't reach sexual
maturity until they're about ten years
old
Peru's fisheries have a long tradition
many poor communities in the north of
the country like Cerritos depend
primarily on their fishing industry in
2012 forsberg and her team made it their
mission to convince local fishermen how
important it is to protect the giant
manta ray officially the fishermen don't
aim to catch the massive creatures but
if one happened to swim into their net
some were not unhappy to bring it in in
2015 Edgardo Cruz caught an especially
big one we thought it was small but when
we tried to drag it aboard it was huge
and because we had someone interested my
colleagues wanted to bring it in and
sell it the catch made headlines around
the world forsberg used the incident to
convince the Peruvian government to ban
fishing giant manta rays that's been her
biggest success so far but it's just a
beginning
I want people to commit to protecting
the species we have to start at the
roots so we need to look for alternative
solutions like offering business
opportunities that also help protect the
manta rays and we need to support
educational efforts and raise awareness
in the communities a regulation alone
won't be enough to protect them Forsberg
and her NGO Planeta Oceano or planet
ocean are based in the Peruvian capital
of Lima their projects to conserve
marine and coastal environments have
received numerous awards
the most lucrative so far was the
100,000 Swiss franc Rolex award the
organization used the prize money for
their manta ray project in Cerritos it
enabled them to fund the training of 10
fishermen from the surrounding area to
provide marine passenger transportation
earning this diploma is one step toward
their goal of starting up a business for
eco-tourists to view giant manta rays
create a sustainable business
opportunity here people will be able to
come from all over the world to swim
with the giant manta rays a fisherman
takes you out to the sea and tells you
about his life and his experiences that
will be a unique experience one single
excursion would earn the fisherman as
much as they make in two weeks of
fishing the equivalent of about a
hundred and fifty euros it's an
appealing prospect so they're happy to
navigate their way through all the red
tape is not going so well the training
we're getting now will open up a better
future for us fishermen Planeta Oceano
is also cooperating with more than 50
schools horse bird has founded a network
for marine education to encourage the
teaching of ocean conservation she
conducts workshops for children and
trains teachers she wants learning to be
fun
you have manta rays and sharks you take
a long time to reproduce if you're
caught you have to leave for 45 seconds
pretty soon all the mantas and sharks
have been caught they have to wait on
the sidelines until they've reproduced
play makes it easy to understand to
reproduce the manta rays are at risk of
extinction
don't kill them a living giant manta ray
is more valuable than a dead one
so casting Forsberg wants to make the
children into ambassadors for marine
conservation and promote sustainable
conservation the ocean giant both
imposing and in need of protection